murder ever to shortstop position to win
omar vasquel got one got him in the
elbow the road trip started with mike
trout being hit in the elbow cost him a
couple of games he made his way back now
one of the other faces of the franchise
takes one in the elbow on that padding
and keep in mind he is a right-handed
thrower and as a left-handed batter you
expose that throwing arm to a pitch
inside
that is the right pitching arm of shohei
oh tony let's see it again runs a
fastball in that's the padding
padding and then there's a different
type of pad on the elbow itself seems
like he's going to be all right adam
leville is checking that strength in his
hand you can see that that grip on a
shake of a hand closure it looks like
he's going to be okay
show he's on the move and the pitch that
one is taking and ohtani's going to
steal second without a throw
easy stolen base right there he goes
first move it soon as sheffield picks
the leg up and he is not quick to home
plate a guy you can run on if you guess
right
he took off to third here's the throw
down he swiped it
shohei running wild on the base pad
trying to get in that dugout get some
treatment six stall bases now with seven
attempts
and when you're already in scoring
position at home you go why is he trying
to steal unless you feel comfortable
you're gonna be able to get this rather
easily now you've taken a potential
pitch in the dirt and get a run out of
it that way
ground ball crawford swung over
and that takes care of the angels on the
top of the first sheffield gets out of a
jab
one out runners on the corners max
stassi number nine hitting catcher
strike three call
out red stassi not pleased for a
strikeout for justice sheffield today
two outs two on fletcher the batter
sheffield hoping to leave two on here in
the second
runners get their leads
the 0-1 pitch to fletcher here she comes
swinging a fly ball into the gap in the
right center field on the run hagerty
and he makes the catch
sam hagerty is able to get back in time
out toward the warning track a fine
ronnie catch by hagerty and that will
retire the side and sheffield
avoids another threat by the angels
runners on the corners one out another
good hitter here's jared walsh
ground ball dylan moore crawford on to
first base in time for the double play
sheffield gets out of it again thanks to
the twin killing
mitch haniger struck out back in the
first inning
great pitch right over the top of that
hammer disappeared so now two outs with
two on and here is second baseman dylan
moore
jammed and it's a base hit here comes
seeger he's burning
home bobbled for a moment by trout dylan
moore just keeps on driving and runs
against the angels
puts the mariners in front one to
nothing in the bottom of the fourth
inside out swing
serves out into center field mike this
is uh the baseball guys paying him back
yeah for a uh a month of tough cooking
two down fletcher at first base
trout the batter
hard hit but right to crawford
jp has it
justice sheffield grinding his way
through five scoreless against the
angels
now you turn the line up over infield in
for the angels haniger stepping in
trout sizing it up terence is at third
trout the catch terence coming home
throws way up the line and terence
scores standing
mitch haniger has made this a
two-nothing game get them on get them
over bring them in
they'll face anthony rindon to begin
things
strike three call
how about that to dot the
corner about 93 miles an hour right at
the bottom of the strike zone
tied him up he was looking out over the
plate a number of the fastballs were
away and set up away again but this time
it's on the inner half sheffield a
chance to finish
a solid six innings now facing pujols
2-2 to pujols
swaying in the midst and the bat goes
down the left-field line almost to the
umpire
down to third temp tim it's folding big
time on a
slow breaking ball fourth strikeout for
sheffield sixth inning out walk to louis
marmalajos will be in the next batter
and the rest of the
i mean just went right adam split the
plate i wonder if he's all right on that
delivery he said max das he's walking
out but he said he's okay
now he muscled up on that one
let's check on the health of dylan bunny
is delivered looks like landed wrong
maybe
front leg twisted
the foot
bundy's
going to continue two outs here in this
inning
bouncing ball out toward third rendon
three steps in
one strong throw on a cross all right
two and one the count
there we go right field slices away
afterburners are on touching first
heading into second
it's a double
for david fletcher
perfect matchup for fletch
pitcher will run that fastball
especially with some movement upstairs
lines it right field double and a runner
in scoring position with ohtani coming
up and masavich coming in
hard hit grounder right into the shift
dylan moore plenty of time
to end the top of the misevich one pitch
does his job aaron slager's
tall sinker throwing right hander takes
over
the number nine man
double whammy for slaggers
there he goes
and his second base and he is in with
his fifth steal of the season
he makes it look easy
so back to back two out walks now
france will be the batter
rendon
fires it on over to fletcher in time for
the out six outs to play with for the
halos looking to get it going
that brings the tying man up to the
plate jared walsh who homer twice last
night
broken back taking its time to crawford
he's got it seeger onto first double
play
and the inning is over here's montero to
get the final three outs now facing
pujols
strike three call
at the knees
albert didn't like it but when he goes
back and takes another look you'll see
that it is a strike right at the knees
another good fastball montero
looks like draymond just going right
after him
last hope for the angels is jose
iglesias two outs nobody on
and play seeger staying with it from the
grass and that's the ball game the
mariners win it they take the series